PRESIDENT TRUMP: SHE THINKS IT’S
POLITICS I DON’T THINK IT’S GOOD
POLITICS.
NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN BLOCKING
IT, SCHUMER HAS BEEN BLOCKING IT
AND I THINK THEY THINK IT’S GOOD
POLITICS.
I DON’T THINK IT’S GOOD POLITICS
I THINK IT’S BAD POLITICS BUT I
DON’T CARE ABOUT THE POLITICS.
IT’S SO GREAT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
NANCY PELOSI IS BLOCKING IT SHE
SITS IN HER HOUSE IN SAN
FRANCISCO OVERLOOKING THE OCEAN
AND SHE DOESN’T WANT TO COME
BACK.
SHE DOESN’T WANT TO COME BACK TO
D.C.
SHE’S GOT TO GET BACK AND GET
THIS THING APPROVED IT’S
VERY IMPORTANT.
PETE: THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY AT THE BRIEFING
TALKING ABOUT THE PROSPECTS OF A
DEAL TO REPLENISH THE COFFERS OF
THE  PPP PROGRAM THAT’S HELPED
AND COULD HELP SO MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES.
LET’S BRING IN CALIFORNIA GOP
CONGRESSMAN DEVON NUNES RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
WAYS AND MEANS COMMITTEE AS WELL
CONGRESSMAN THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
WHERE ARE WE RIGHT NOW?
AND IS NANCY PELOSI PLAYING AN
ABOVE-FORWARD GAME HERE AND
WHERE ARE WE IN GETTING A DEAL?
>> WELL THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
ON.
PETE: OF COURSE.
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY IS IF ANY
REPUBLICAN LEADER IF MITCH
MCCONNELL OR  KEVIN MCCARTHY OR
ANY OF OUR SPEAKERS IN THE PAST
WOULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING LIKE
PELOSI DID WHERE SHE’S SITTING
AT HOME IN FRONT OF HER
REFRIGERATOR WITH A $24,000
FREEZER THAT I DON’T THINK TOO
MANY OF US HAVE EXCEPT MAYBE FOR
GRIFF I THINK HE MAY HAVE
ONE.
PETE: HE MIGHT.
JILLIAN: [LAUGHTER]
>> BUT HERE IS THE DEAL.
IT BE A FATAL FLAW.
WE WOULD BOOT MCCONNELL OR
MCCARTHY OUT OF LEADERSHIP JUST
LIKE THAT.
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN OUT FOUR
DAYS AGO THE MINUTE THAT POPPED
UP.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE, 20 MILLION
PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED AND YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT CAN’T GET PAYCHECKS
YOU JUST HAD ON THE LAST SEGMENT
THEY CAN’T EVEN MOW THEIR DAMN
LAW IN MICHIGAN WHAT THE
HELL IS GOING ON AND SHE’S
SITTING IN SAN FRANCISCO EATING
GOURMET ICE CREAM?
IT DOESN’T FLY OUT IN THE
REAL-WORLD.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, FILL
DISCLOSURE MY FRIDGE IS SO TINY
MY DAUGHTERS COMPLAIN WE CAN
BARELY GET ONE PINT OF ICE CREAM
IN THERE BUT LET ME ASK YOU
BECAUSE PELOSI PUT OUT A LETTER
YESTERDAY LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE
TALKS ARE ONGOING AND SHE’S
FEELING CONFIDENT ABOUT PROGRESS
BEING MADE.
CAN YOU TAKE US INSIDE WHAT
YOU’RE HEARING ABOUT TALKS AND
HOW CLOSE WE ARE TO ACTUALLY SEE
>> WELL, WE HAD A CONFERENCE
CALL YESTERDAY.
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE SCHEDULED
FOR TONIGHT.
I KNOW THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
MCCARTHY IS ON HIS WAY BACK TO
WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW AND WE’LL
HAVE ANOTHER CONFERENCE CALL SO
THE IDEA IS SHE WOULD PLUS UP
THE MONEY FOR THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION, SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
PEOPLE EMPLOYED AND ALSO GIVE
MONEY FOR HOSPITALS.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOGICAL GREAT
PLAN, HAS HUGE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, I THINK IT’S ONE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD
UNDERSTAND.
JILLIAN: DO YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE
IT’LL GET DONE THIS WEEK?
>> WELL, I WOULD THINK SO.
IT’S LIKE I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING WHEN YOU HAVE A LEADER
THAT MAKES SUCH A FATAL FLAW,
WHAT BE A FATAL FLAW FOR A
REPUBLICAN, FOR A DEMOCRAT THE
MEDIA IS COVERING UP, FOX
AND A FEW OTHERS ARE THE ONLY
ONES COVERING THAT, BUT IF YOU
HAVE MITCH MCCONNELL WITH A
BUNCH OF GOURMET ICE CREAM, HE
BE THROWN OUT OF LEADERSHIP
IMMEDIATELY.
PETE: TOTALLY RIGHT DOUBLE
STANDARDS GLARING.
BY THE WAY CAN YOU PREVENT ANY
KENNEDY CENTER-TYPE FUNDING AS
WE SAW IN THE LAST ONE WHERE
THEY SLIPPED IN MONEY FOR THEIR
FRIENDS OR  ARE THEY GOING TO
TRY TO DO THAT AGAIN?
>> THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN PREVENT
IT IS BY NOT GIVING THEM THE
VOTE, BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY YOU HAVE TO JUDGE, IS IT
OKAY TO NOT BE PAYING PEOPLE
THAT CAN’T MOW THEIR LAWN IN
MICHIGAN?
VERSUS $25 MILLION FOR WHATEVER
THE HELL THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
USE FOR THE KENNEDY CENTER WHICH
I SAID LAST WEEK ON YOUR SHOW
STILL HAS NOT BEEN TURNED INTO A
COVID RESPONSE CENTER LAST TIME
I CHECKED.
PETE: VERY VERY TRUE.
GRIFF: LET ME TAKE YOU TO A
DIFFERENT TOPIC FOR JUST A
MOMENT.
PETE HAS BEEN EGGING ME ON.
I’VE REALLY BEEN PRESSING HARD
ON CHINA.
THE PRESIDENT WARNED CHINA IT
COULD BE FACING CONSEQUENCES
YESTERDAY AND OF COURSE, YOU’VE
GOT VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WEIGH
ING IN AS WELL.
LET ME GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID ABOUT
CHINESE CONSEQUENCES AND GET
YOUR REACTION.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WELL IF THEY
WERE KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE
CERTAINLY IF IT WAS A MISTAKE, A
MISTAKE IS A MISTAKE, BUT IF
THEY WERE KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE
YEAH THEN THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT POTENTIALLY
LIVES LIKE NOBODY HAS SEEN SINCE
1917.
I THINK YOU HAVE NUMEROUS
COUNTRIES WAITING TO SEE WHETHER
OR  NOT SLEEPY JOE WINS BECAUSE
IF SLEEPY JOE WON THEY OWN OUR
COUNTRY.
FOR YEARS I’VE HEARD BY 2019
CHINA WILL CATCH US.
THERE’S ONLY ONE PROBLEM TRUMP
GOT ELECTED IN 2016.
PETE: [LAUGHTER]
GRIFF: YOUR REACTION?
>> SO THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS
HAVE BEEN RUNNING AN
INVESTIGATION INTO CHINA ON
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE FOR
MANY MANY YEARS.
WE WERE THE FIRST TO IDENTIFY
THAT WE HAD A 5G PROBLEM THAT
HUAWEI AND ZTE CHINESE COMPANIES
WERE LOOKING TO OWN ALL OF THE
NETWORKS ALL OVER THE GLOBE,
SO WE’VE BEEN ON THIS FOR A
WHILE AND REMEMBER, WE WERE
DEALING WITH THE RUSSIA HOAX IN
THE LAST CONGRESS.
AT THE SAME TIME THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WERE TRYING TO RUN
AN INVESTIGATION INTO CHINA, AND
THE DEMOCRATS FINALLY, WE HAD A
PUBLIC HEARING ON THIS AND THEY
HIJACKED THE HEARING TO TRY TO
SUBPOENA WHATEVER RUSSIAN OF THE
WEEK THEY WERE LOOKING AFTER
AND SO THIS HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE
FOR US TO GET CHINA ON THE
FOREFRONT.
I THINK NOW, BOTH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS REALIZE THIS AND
I’LL JUST TO FINISH THAT, THE
ISSUE WITH THIS VIRUS AND
CHINA, THE UNUSUAL PART FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THIS IS JUST
HOW CONTAGIOUS THIS VIRUS HAS
BEEN, AND WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW
IS DID THEY DO SOMETHING TO THIS
VIRUS TO SPEED IT UP AND I
THINK THAT’S THE REAL QUESTION.
PETE: FOR SURE.
YOU MENTIONED THE INVESTIGATION,
GOT TO GET YOUR TAKE.
NEWLY UNCLASSIFIED FOOTNOTES
SHOW THAT THE FBI KNEW THAT
DOCUMENTS USED FOR FISA WARRANTS
WERE BOGUS.
EXPLAIN THIS.
>> SO WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE SEEING IS EVERYTHING IS
COMING INTO CLEAR VIEW, WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT FOR A WHILE, THE
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DECLASSIFIED.
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF DOCUMENTS
DECLASSIFIED IN THE LAST WEEK.
I’D SUMMIT UP LIKE THIS AND THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
FOLKS THAT FOLLOW THIS
RUSSIA HOAX CLOSELY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THERE’S
ESSENTIALLY THREE WHAT I’D CALL
PHONY DOCUMENTS, ALSO CALLED A
DOSSIER.
YOU HAVE THE STEELE CLINTON
FUSION GPS DOSSIER THAT THE FBI
WAS INVOLVED IN, THERE’S A BUNCH
OF QUESTIONS THERE DURHAM IS
LOOKING AT.
YOU HAVE THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ASSESSMENT THAT WAS
DONE BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DAYS OF 2016 BEFORE
OBAMA LEFT OFFICE AND DONALD
TRUMP CAME IN.
REMEMBER THAT WAS THE DOCUMENT
THAT SAID OH, YEAH THE RUSSIANS
WERE TRYING TO HELP TRUMP.
WELL NOW WE KNOW THERE’S LOTS OF
LIES AND OMISIONS WHICH I WOULD
SAY NOT ONLY MISLEAD CONGRESS,
BUT MISLEAD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE THIRD DOSSIER IS WHAT PEOPLE
CALL THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE MUELLER REPORT, I CALL THE
MUELLER DOSSIER, OKAY?
BECAUSE IT’S ALSO FILLED WITH
BOTH LIES AND OMISIONS, AND
REMEMBER YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED OVER THIS ,
THAT HAVE ALREADY SPENT TIME IN
JAIL OVER THIS.
WHY WHEN MUELLER AND HIS TEAM,
THIS GREAT TEAM OF EXPERTS THAT
DOJ AND FBI THEY BROUGHT ALL
THESE PEOPLE IN, WHERE THE HELL
IS ALL OF THAT INFORMATION NOW
THAT YOU GUYS ARE ALL NOW SEEING
FOR THE FIRST TIME HERE IN THE
LAST WEEK?
WHY DID WE NOT KNOW ABOUT GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS BEING OFFERED THIS
MONEY, OKAY FROM RUSSIA.
WHO WERE THOSE RUSSIANS AND SO
MOVING FORWARD YOU HAVE THE
THREE DOSSIERS THAT HAVE TO
BE INVESTIGATED.
I’M ALSO INTERESTED IN THREE
RUSSIANS THAT ACTUALLY RUSSIAN
AMERICANS THAT WE’RE LOOKING
INTO AND THEN I WOULD SAY FINAL
LY, IN 2016 WE KNOW FROM
GREAT WORKS THAT TREY GOWDY DID
AT THE TIME IN QUESTIONING THAT
THE  CIA GAVE INFORMATION OVER
TO THE FBI IN 2016.
WE NOW ARE LASER FOCUSED ON THAT
WE NEED TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT DID
THE CIA GIVE TO THE FBI IN 2016?
THAT’S WHAT OUR INVESTIGATION IS
NOW FOCUSING ON.
GRIFF: IT’LL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE IF WE GET THAT CONGRESSMAN I
DOUBT THEY OPEN THAT IN THE
HOUSE, AND MAYBE SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO NOW RUNS THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL
TAKE A DEEPER LOOK.
PETE: YOU’VE BEEN ON THE CASE
FOR THE BEGINNING THANKS FOR
STAYING ON IT CONGRESSMAN WE
APPRECIATE YOU.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND GRIFF YOUR MU
LLETT IS LOOKING GOOD,